i always feel like you should start
writing when right when you feel you're
not quite ready you know i think that's
the time to start because i think if you
keep researching and researching and
researching
you're just kind of you're holding off
on the real work you know because that's
not the real work
how do you keep an underlying sense of
danger and tension in every scene i
think um a lot of that is
part of the setting you know
understanding understanding the location
lets you
kind of describe it in a mysterious
dangerous way you know i think if you if
you have a feeling for the location
where you know is it a seedy area is it
a high crime area is it a rich wealthy
area you know like what
what kind of things are either likely to
happen to you there or what might be
surprising to happen to you there
depending on the direction you want the
scene to go but i think for me
uh
a lot of that comes down to knowing the
location and really getting a feel for
it i know that might sound weird because
it's not directly related but that's
usually what i go to first you know it's
like
what is the mood of this area then how
can i sort of color that mood to be a
little bit more dangerous
so let's say
someone how would you say that this
character thomas cain is a chameleon in
some sense he can really blend in
so how is he operating when walking
through a bad part of town whereas he's
walking through a business center where
there's professionals with nice leather
shoes um most of the stories actually
tend to take place in more kind of
seedier locations so i think he's
probably more at home in
more dangerous areas like i mean he
there have been er usually if he's in an
area
that's more upscale he just kind of acts
like a tourist you know he acts like
kind of a clueless tourist because he
knows that's the most likely scenario
for why someone like him might be there
um
but i don't know in terms of making the
audience feel like something can happen
i feel like you sort of need to have a
sense of the locale you know there's a
you know the book three that's set in
sudan
um you know that's a war-torn region
and so i you know i really tried to kind
of play up the you know the condition of
the buildings and there's armed soldiers
walking around everywhere and you know
everyone's kind of
on edge and you see like smoke rising
from a building somewhere because it was
bombed you know the previous day like
you know those kinds of details i think
are what make the reader start to think
like oh wow anything could happen here
like you know who knows like
so i think i to me it kind of comes down
to the location and and communicating
that to the reader
it's interesting that you said that he
would pretend he was a tourist and i had
heard that from a journalist on a panel
she said that when she would go into
certain war-torn countries she would
very much put on like a a touristy garb
and because she was less of a threat
right and and so people overlooked her
yeah which is very interesting yeah
i mean if you're you know if you're a
white guy walking around china you know
like they're really only a few things
that are plausible and why you would be
there so
i see so so he kind of has a camera and
and i know he doesn't go that far with
it but he just sort of
that just tends to be kind of the
rationale or he just you know kind of
pretends he might you know he might
pretend he doesn't understand the
language even if he does or he might ask
for you know in one
scene uh he asks someone for directions
right before he attacks them you know
because he's just trying to play off
that he's like a lost tourist you know
things like that
we imagine there's many many times
you've put thomas kane in some
impossible position where it seemed like
he wasn't going to get out
is there an example that you can use
where you backed yourself into a corner
and how did you get out of it so you're
writing and you're like wait a minute
how am i getting out of this scene i
don't have a plan for it sure
um
actually in the very first book uh the
climax takes place on a
thing called tokyo skytree
actually when i started writing it took
place on something called tokyo tower
but in the years that it took to finish
the book
uh tokyo tower
became no longer the tallest structure
in japan you know that when i started it
was when i finished it was this thing
called tokyo skytree so i moved it
because i thought it would be more
exciting to be the tallest you know
building in japan
so tokyo skytree is this big big tower i
think it's about a half a mile tall with
like a little observation
deck at the top and
i knew i wanted to have a scene with
kane you know fighting people at the top
of this tower
and uh there's like a drone zooming
around them and all this stuff going on
you know for the outline that's about as
much detail as i would do but when i
started writing it i was like well
okay
at some point he's gonna be hanging off
the tower and then what you know like
what do i do like obviously he can't
fall but how do i make it interesting
that he doesn't fall you know like what
does he do is just pull himself back up
or like what makes the bad guy
uh go away you know or like and so i was
sort of stuck you know i wasn't really
sure what to do
but it for me the answer just came down
to uh research i just kept researching
it was really hard to find accurate uh
blueprints or pictures of the tower i
don't know why but so i just had to keep
at it you know most things when i
research i can usually find what i'm
looking for pretty quickly but for
whatever reason it just i just had a
hard time finding detailed enough
pictures where i could sort of plot out
the scene in my head
finally i found this video
of
people washing the windows at the top of
the tower
and they have these little carts that
like lower down and then move along on
tracks
and i was like that's it you know and so
in the scene i had him spot one of these
carts that's like hanging you know half
up and he like is able to swing himself
into the cart
um and then he has to like you know
climb the wire and jump onto there's
this big like glass tube that wraps
around the top of the tower where it's
like an up where you can look you know
360 from this observation deck so we had
to like jump onto this tube and you know
fight the guy on top of this glass tube
like way above the city and so
the research just you know just not
giving up on the research is really what
allowed me to kind of finish that scene
in a satisfying way
if you can't find what you're looking
for with the research at what point do
you move on do you give yourself a time
limit or is that part of the fun i mean
i certainly wouldn't
i wouldn't stay on it for forever i mean
i do think you have to keep things
moving and so if you're not finding what
you need i think you i at some point you
either
change the scene like you go back or you
just come up with something else i mean
i think really it all comes down to
what's satisfying for you right because
that scene i just described i'm sure you
could give that to 10 other writers and
they'd come up with 10 other ways to
make that interesting you know there's
all kinds of things you could do but
nothing was clicking for me you know so
i think at a certain point if you don't
find the answer then yeah you either
need to just try a different tact or
maybe go back okay well maybe he doesn't
fall off maybe he throws the guy off and
then realizes the guy has something he
needs you know and he has to get him
back or you know i don't know you just
try to
find what would be interesting and work
from there i do think actually um
i think a lot of people
over research and you know i love
research and it's important but i think
that a lot of people use research as
kind of an excuse to not get started you
know
and i think that that's
a danger actually i always try to i
always feel like you should start
writing when right when you feel you're
not quite ready you know i think that's
the time to start because i think if you
keep researching and researching and
researching
you're just kind of you're holding off
on the real work you know because that's
not the real work
and also i've found that
i i think you'd be surprised what you
can get away with you know because if
there's something
you don't know
you just don't point the metaphoric or
the literal camera at it you know i mean
the novella took place in thailand
and i needed a scene by a river and i
was kind of driving myself crazy trying
to find like where would a river be in
this region and
you know i couldn't find anything and
finally i just said you know why am i
going through all this trouble i just
said yeah i just cut you know i just
started the new chapter and he's by a
river i don't say exactly where it is no
one has ever like said well where could
there be a river in this province of
thailand if you only had this many out
you know i think that people overdo it
on that kind of stuff so
uh you know i do do what you need to
kind of
get yourself invested and interested and
i think you can do a lot as you go from
that point on you know the internet's
always there
do you limit yourself though do you turn
like the wi-fi on it's not a no it's not
like a literal time i just kind of have
a sense now from having done it like you
know you're you're putting it off now
you're putting it off you know it's like
you're putting off the work you're
researching too much you got to just get
going you know i just kind of have a
sense in my head of when it's time to
start writing but do you turn off your
email and different text messages not
really uh
sometimes every now and then i will but
most of the time i'm able to just ignore
it you know
you know i'll put my phone in the other
room maybe